hello and welcome to c 0 utta roxas
again we both seem to play a long
session here we had a bit noisy earlier
when he was in huge trouble out of the
opening let's see if he has some great
improvement in store sugar g5 here and
probably yes okay so maybe just f3
oh it's like it to answer be five with a
TSA takes before maybe I get this going
here as well and he has to play Bishop
d7 first not sure that i should play
troop you want that quick leave it okay
it's a it's an ok move I guess
good started with Queen d2 at least and
anyway g5 are you serious ok I'm coming
and going back now so sorry I don't
believe in stuff like that at all plex
King side is full of weaknesses and I
don't really see much of dynamic play on
the queenside White has all the fun
though
hmm
yeah Black has to has to try to muddy
the waters so the only only chance not
sure I don't think taking was great got
enough stuff they're working change the
b7 porn or the other one then this be
five but I then I do not give 94 and
then it's also good I get to get to go
to F 595 that's not f5 so it's night at
five isn't that winning I don't don't
get it I Queenie 6 or something is that
really working I don't know Queenie six
I can take on d5 with the pawn no and
between f6 especially for
yeah 25 next and modern benoni is
incredibly difficult opening to play if
black misplaced it looks like the worst
opening in the world if it if everything
works for black it looks like the best
opening in the world black resins young
to be honest I'm very skeptical about
this kind of position for black but of
course some people to play it and with
some flicks with some success but a
couple of things i'm not a g5 I don't
believe it we now understand that
there's some play on the dark squares
but I mean I'm white is essentially
winning on the queenside and wears black
skull to play I really don't see
anything engine is on 1.5 already and
into climbing probably check know in
what and winning plus two already yeah
things get lost now or you get to f5 so
into the wide wins the house a black
just created too many weaknesses I guess
I'm kind of skeptical about Queenie
seven as well but in combination with g5
it's definitely bad it's too many it's
just too many weaknesses and too little
in terms of concrete counter play okay
well thanks for watching